raketeneinschläge häuserkämpfe
verzweiflung
solch ein krieg im herzen europas so
dachte man gehört der vergangenheit an
einstige gewissheiten erschüttert die
nato steht so eng zusammen wie es vor
kurzem noch kaum einer für möglich
gehalten hätte aus amerika kommen
soldaten waffen geld joe biden gelingt
es den westen zusammenzuschweißen obwohl
oder gerade weil putin mit einem
atomkrieg gedroht
die usa haben den köder nicht geschluckt
und sich nicht auf putins atom spiel
eingelassen
ich denke joe biden hat bisher einen
guten job gemacht die nato-staaten
zusammenzuhalten mit den gemeinsamen
statement abgestimmten handlungen und so
weiter er hat also die nato
gewissermaßen wieder belebt nach all dem
schaden den tramp der allianz zugefügt
hat
der ukraine krieg auch bei joe bidens
erster state ob die junien das
beherrschende thema
putin dachte der westen und die nato
würden nicht reagieren
und er dachte er könnte uns spalten hier
in unserer nation und in europa
putin hat sich getäuscht und jetzt daher
angegriffen hat zieht in die freie welt
zur rechenschaft
wir fügen russland schmerzen zu und
unterstützen das ukrainische volk putin
ist isolierter von der welt als je zuvor
die lage eskaliert zu einer zeit in der
americas im innern extrem unter druck
steht pandemie inflation spritpreise das
nur einige der vielen innenpolitischen
feuer die joe biden versucht
gleichzeitig zu löschen und jede neue
russland sanktionen wirkt sich auch
negativ auf die eigene wirtschaft aus
während europa die neue geschlossenheit
des westens feiert muss der us-präsident
viel überzeugungsarbeit leisten mehr als
40 prozent der eingetragenen
republikaner haben sympathien für putin
und sein autoritäres system
es gibt zwei separatisten staaten in der
ukraine die ethnisch vor allem russisch
sind sie identifizieren sich einfach
mehr mit russland putin hat doch nur
ihre unabhängigkeit anerkannt und
truppen geschickt er ist also eigentlich
gar nicht in die ukraine einmarschiert
sondern in ein anderes land
dieser krieg ist das resultat schwacher
führung das wäre unter der vorigen
administration nicht passiert wir
schicken truppen nach polen ungarn
rumänien warum sichern wir nicht erst
mal unsere eigenen grenzen das wäre
sinnvoll
das zeigt dass heute und das gilt nicht
nur für die vereinigten staaten sondern
auch für unsere europäischen alliierten
viele außenpolitische diskussionen sehr
viel stärker innenpolitisch legitimiert
werden müssen als das noch im krieg der
fall war und die tatsache dass joe biden
in gewisser weise zwar nicht die hände
gebunden sind aber eher sehr darauf
achten muss diesen drahtseilakt zu
verbringen zwischen vollbringen zwischen
innen- und außenpolitischen fragen dass
es da das zeichen einer neuen zeit
diese neue zeit spielt den rechten in
amerika in die karten
mehr und mehr republikaner ziehen sich
in ihre desinformations blasen zurück
wie trumps neue social media plattformen
lügen und aggression als politisches
kampfinstrument truth wahrheit wird zur
auslegungssache die tatsache dass so
viele konservative in den vereinigten
staaten sich nicht bereits in so einer
situation auf die seite des präsidenten
zu schlagen ist in der tat eine neue
situation es gibt umfragen belegen dass
unter republikanischen wählerinnen und
wählern wladimir putin beliebter ist als
zu beiden das ist eine neue
innenpolitische situation weil wir es
zum ersten mal mit einer starken anti
westlichen gesinnung im zentrum des
westens zu tun haben mit unabsehbaren
politischen folgen
dafür ist maßgeblich er verantwortlich
putin sei ein schlauer mann wird trump
nicht müde zu betonen zuletzt am
wochenende bei der sie pack einer
konferenz der us konservativen im wilden
rausch fegt er weiter über das land
während in der ukraine unschuldige
sterben aber trump geht es um trump und
der kann wut einfach besser als mit
gefühl
es könnte zu einem richtig großen krieg
in europa kommen so frank rieger an
genauso
joe biden hat ruhe in chaos verwandelt
kompetenz in inkompetenz
stabilität in anarchie und sicherheit in
eine katastrophe
zu diesem schrecklichen desaster wäre es
nie gekommen wenn uns die wahl nicht
gestohlen worden und ich präsident wäre
trumps als ikone eines großen teils
einer schlagzeilen süchtigen
gesellschaft der ehemalige
us-oberbefehlshaber fordert die
demokratie unverhohlen heraus
[Musik]
und so wird auch die wichtigste
verpflichtung unsere werte zu
verteidigen schwieriger denn die
angriffe auf unsere art zu leben werden
immer massiver und vielen ist längst
klar dass man sich für demokratie aktiv
einsetzen muss dass man allianzen und
partnerschaften schmieden muss und dass
er nicht ausreicht zu glauben man könne
in der mitte europas oder sogar hier in
den vereinigten staaten
die früchte des ende des kalten krieges
genießen und gleichzeitig sich nicht
darum kümmern was in anderen
weltgegenden passiert glaube die letzten
tage waren ein crashkurs wenn man das so
sagen ein bild für eine neue
transatlantische allianz eine stärkung
der nato und hoffentlich auch eine
stärkung der europäischen union doch
selbst wenn der westen weiter zusammen
steht er wird immer ein stück weit
machtlos bleiben gegenüber einem mann
der den finger am roten knopf hat
[Musik]